- It's hard.
It's hard.
I know you know what to do.
It's like close your eyes for four years.
Nothing good is gonna
happen for four years.
So I just got out of a meeting.
How is it going?
- Good.
How are you?
- Really well.
I didn't even know that
Taylor was coming in today,
and it took me a second.
You probably can see it.
I'm like holy shit.
So this is super exciting for me even.
What you're about to watch
is a follow up meeting to no question.
Go, go, go, go.
The most viral moment of
the Ask Gary Vee Show.
Here's the full Ask Gary Vee moment
with the follow up
interview that I just did,
or the catch up that I just did.
I genuinely believe in my heart and soul
that for everybody 22, that 98% of people
that are 22 to 30 are about
to get a piece of content
that is fundamentally
gonna change your life.
- So I'm not sure if you
remember about a year ago
I actually called in.
Well I got called into
the Ask Gary Vee Show,
so I talked to you about a year ago.
I'm from Buffalo.
- Right, I remember.
(phone ringing)
- [Taylor] Hello.
- Hey Taylor, it's Gary Vee.
You're on the Ask Gary Vee Show.
- [Taylor] No way.
- Yes way.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Where you from?
- [Taylor] Sweet.
I'm from Buffalo, New York.
- I love it.
Are you a Bills fan?
- [Taylor] Unfortunately yes.
- Alright, I know you said
unfortunately cause you're--
- [Taylor] We're not very good.
- Well listen, neither are the Jets.
Don't worry.
So, what's going on?
- [Taylor] (laughs) Nothing much.
I basically have been dying
to ask you a question.
Currently graduated college last May,
and I'm trying to build my own business,
brand, hustle, all that kind of stuff,
and my question for you is,
and I'm probably sure that
a lot of people ask this,
or wondering the same thing.
- It's okay.
- [Taylor] How do you get over the stump
of you're graduating and
you feel all this pressure
'cause you're trying to build something,
but you're still so young
but you wanna do this fast,
grow it big, and I'm just in a rut,
and I can't get out of it, but
I have a hustle and a drive
that I know I'll be
able to build something,
but I'm just in this space
that's not allowing me to.
- So let me help you.
The space you're in is
probably the macro micro issue.
So it's macro patience,
micro speed, right.
So what do I mean by that?
You need to be patient as fuck, Taylor.
You're 22, 23 years old.
Like what do you think's
gonna happen overnight?
- [Taylor] Yeah, I know.
- So you need to be fast.
7:00 a.m. 'til two in
the morning everyday,
but in the big picture you need to realize
nothing good is gonna happen
for the next six years.
- [Taylor] Okay.
And do you think that I should
just try every good idea
that I think I have and
just go for it all out,
or do you think I should stick
with one thing at a time?
- I think the fact that you
even asked that question
that you should taste flirting
with a lot of different things
because you'll be crippled
by the what if if you don't,
even though that's not the perfect formula
to build the biggest short term wealth
because you should go
triple down on one thing
instead of being half pregnant on nine.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Taylor, let me tell you something.
Like, let me ask you the pressure.
Like are you trying to prove to yourself,
to your siblings, to your
parents, to the world,
like who you trying to prove
that you're successful to
or that this was the right
call or you're gonna make it?
Like that's what you have to figure.
- [Taylor] That's a good question.
- Like what are you impatient for?
Like what's the problem?
You wanna buy a fucking Rolex?
Like what's the rush?
- [Taylor] I feel like I've known
that I'm meant to do something big.
- Me too.
- [Taylor] And I grew up in
an entrepreneurial house.
- Me too.
- [Taylor] And so it's in my blood.
It's in my bones.
- Good.
- [Taylor] And I feel like I watch
all these other millennials
hitting these huge,
I guess milestones in their life.
- What milestones?
- [Taylor] And then I'm sitting here--
- Let's break it down.
How old are you?
- [Taylor] I'm 22 about to be 23.
- Okay, what milestone?
Please give me a millennial
and the milestone they achieved
that makes you feel like you're just
sitting in fucking Buffalo?
- [Taylor] Well, I'm sitting in Buffalo,
which is one thing I'm not happy about.
- That's right 'cause it's
home of the Buffalo Bills.
Piece of shit team.
But before you go there, forget
about sitting in Buffalo.
Who's the millennial
and what's the milestone
that's making you feel
like you're sitting there?
Go.
The truth, go.
- [Taylor] Well honestly
there's people in social media,
which definitely is not always true.
- Who?
- [Taylor] But I watch, oh God,
I guess the only thing on
the spot I can think of
is a Kardashian or a
Jenner which is lame but.
- Can we talk about this please?
- [Taylor] Yeah, I feel like, sure.
- Like you're telling
me that Kylie Jenner's
fucking trillion followers on Instagram
makes you feel like
you're just sitting there?
- [Taylor] No, I feel like the fact
that she's already got a business started
that's super successful obviously
that comes with her fame.
- Did you factor in the
fact that her sisters
and mom architected something for 10 years
while she was a teenager that she was able
to walk directly into that
gave her a springboard
and that she had the
financial capabilities
of deploying unGodly
amounts of plastic surgery
and all the other variable things
that she's been able to
do to create that culture
and that financial benefit?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Did you factor in that
her mom is a ninja architect
of business and created that framework?
- [Taylor] Yeah and I
feel like not many people
give them the credit for that.
I totally think that
they built this empire.
- I agree but what the fuck
does that have to do with you?
- [Taylor] It has nothing
to do with me, I know.
- No shit.
Remember how I, I don't
know if you saw this
where I said stop looking
at your friends shit
or whatever the fuck I put on Instagram.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I don't know if you saw it
or not but it doesn't matter.
Like you looking at the
Kardashians is the most
ludicrous horseshit I've
ever heard in my life.
- [Taylor] (laughs) Well
that's just the first thing
that popped into my
head when you asked me.
- Listen we're here.
We're here.
Give me another one.
- [Taylor] There's a guy in London.
I can't think of his name
on the top of my head.
- I'm gonna stop you right now.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Let me give you some,
I was gonna say fatherly.
I guess my father was 40, no.
I'll give you some massively
older brother uncle advice.
You ready?
- [Taylor] Okay yes.
- Every second you spend thinking about
what somebody else has
is taking away from time
that you can create
something for yourself.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- You're losing.
You're losing 'cause
you're laying in your bed
looking at somebody's fucking
glamorous photoshopped picture
of them doing something
cool and you're envious,
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling your upside.
- [Taylor] Yeah 'cause
that's where I wanna be,
and I know I'm not there yet.
- You haven't done shit.
- [Taylor] I know.
- So go do shit that
actually gets you there,
so that you earn it instead
of like you dwelling
that you're not there and
hoping something's gonna happen.
I don't know what's
going through your mind.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
Well I guess I'm hustling on the side,
but I don't think I'm
doing enough I guess.
- You definitely aren't doing enough
if you have enough time to
fucking consume the content
of a Kardashian and some boy in London.
- [Taylor] That's true.
- Taylor, listen to me.
Taylor, listen.
You've gotta deploy patience,
and you've gotta love the process.
I'm addicted to the process
of the battle scars,
the setbacks, the lack of you know.
Taylor, I gave up my entire 20s.
All of 'em.
Imagine not doing anything fun,
or going anywhere for the next eight years
including Saturday and Sunday.
That's what I did from 22 to 30.
Everyday I spent 15 hours
a day in liquor store.
Thought about a liquor store.
Built a liquor store.
Sold wine.
Like spent everyday.
Like this last weekend.
Don't like to me, Taylor.
What did you do this last weekend?
What did you do fucking
Saturday and Sunday?
Tell me the truth.
Don't bullshit me.
- [Taylor] Yeah no bullshit.
I'm helping my mom right
now on visual media
and branding for her company.
- Love you.
- And so I had a marketing meeting
with one of the people doing that.
- Love you.
- [Taylor] And then I also--
- How much time did you have for yourself
on Saturday and Sunday that
was not working every minute?
Tell me the truth.
- [Taylor] A lot.
A lot.
- I know.
So that's the punchline, right.
Now imagine this when I tell you this.
You spent more downtime on
not your career this weekend
then I did in my entire 20s combined.
- [Taylor] Oh shit, okay.
That puts things into perspective.
- I think so.
- [Taylor] Awesome.
- I think so, too.
- [Taylor] Yeah I need to just get to it.
- Taylor, you need to do me a huge favor.
If you really wanna win and you wanna come
to New York in eight
years and shake my hand,
here's what you need to do.
You need to stop giving a shit
about what anybody else has
and realize that if you put your head down
and just work for the next ten years.
No glamour, no new fucking car,
suitcase, jewelry, trip, event.
No Coachella.
No fucking new fucking sneakers.
Like fucking work you will have it,
and every time you care about
one of the things I just mentioned,
it will slow down your
process of having it.
- [Taylor] Okay so in
less than eight years
when I'm a millionaire by 25,
I'll come shake your hand.
- I promise you that statement itself
made me 100% guarantee that you won't.
- [Taylor] No.
- Yes, yes.
That's how this works.
Being a millionaire at 25 when you're 22
and you're a dick shit
and haven't even started.
It's inconceivable unless
you fucking hit the lotto.
What's the romance?
I wanna make.
You know how everybody says Gary Vee
when are you gonna buy
the Jets, in two years?
And I reply 20 years.
I'm romantic about the
journey and the process,
which is why I'm actually
gonna pull it off.
You're trying to be a millionaire by 25.
How Taylor?
- [Taylor] It's just a
goal I've always had.
- Why?
- [Taylor] And right
now with what I'm doing
I guess it's not.
- That's right.
It's an arbitrary bullshit
thing that means nothing.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Wouldn't you rather guarantee
millionaire shit by 36,
then by doing longterm marathon running
versus doing a bunch of bullshit sprints
that guarantees never having it,
and I promise you if anything happens
to your self-esteem when
you're 31 and not a millionaire
because you've been
chasing fast fucking cash
and you're now six years removed
from not hitting your goal,
your self-esteem starts
fucking with your head.
- [Taylor] Mhmm yeah.
- Listen carefully.
I wanna buy the New York Jets,
but when I clarify it to everybody,
I want the process of trying
to buy the New York Jets
more than buying the New York Jets.
Understand?
- [Taylor] Yeah 'cause
ultimately that's the end goal,
but there's a process behind that.
- You have to understand I don't give
a fuck about the end goal.
I care about the process.
The enjoyment of doing it.
You're not enjoying yourself trying
to get to a million bucks
over the next three years.
- [Taylor] No (laughs).
You're right.
- Oh I know I'm right.
I'm just sticking on this right now
because I feel like we've
gone into this deep enough
that I might as well hold
on for a couple more minutes
to see if I can actually pull you through
instead of you just being on this high
of practicality for 36 hours,
and then going back to
Instagram bullshit in 48 hours.
- [Taylor] I need to
deactivate that shit (laughs).
- No, you need to learn to discipline
to be able to put it in the proper bucket.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
I just feel like I hold
myself at this pedestal
only it crippling myself
'cause I'm not actually
doing the things to get there.
- Of course.
So you're playing a fake narrative
instead of putting in the actual work
that's needed to actually pull it off.
Wishing instead of executing.
And then what's happening is you're living
a fake world to yourself but you know it,
which then changes your behavior
in the way you interact with others.
- [Taylor] True.
- I know.
Like for all my vibrato now,
I was real quiet in my 20s.
People made fun of me.
Like you work in your dad's liquor store.
I'm on Wall Street making $100,000.
I got a BMW.
I'm like that's nice, Pat.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Do you understand the level
of disrespect I have for Pat?
Do you understand the
level of disrespect I have
for all those 20, 30, 40, 50 year olds
flashing shit on fucking Instagram.
I can't wait for the
fucking world to melt.
I can't wait for all these bullshit people
to get fucking hosed out
when the economy gets shit.
- [Taylor] Yes, cause
they're short term affording
these things that are flashy,
but in the long term it's not sustainable
for what they're doing right now.
- Yeah but meanwhile you're
admiring the fuck out of them.
- [Taylor] I know.
It's a problem.
- No shit, Taylor.
- [Taylor] It's really bad.
- Taylor, you need to start
fucking loving the process
and the work and the grind.
You need to start respecting people
that are like sleeping
with like four roommates
and buying their tee shirts at Wal-Mart.
- [Taylor] Yeah you know what?
I feel like I need that wake up,
but I feel like I need to hit rock bottom
to have that wake up.
I'm too comfortable right now,
and it's annoying the shit out of me.
- I don't think so.
I think you're saying you
need to hit rock bottom
because it buys you more time to bullshit
like you are right now.
- [Taylor] I never thought of that.
- You know what I mean?
Like you know it's not working.
You're just saying.
By the way, let me go
complete left field on you.
You're a 22 year old girl, woman.
Like, it's okay to enjoy
a little bit now, too.
You've heard me say regrets.
I don't know how deep you know my content,
but once in a blue moon when
people ask me the advice
for 25 year old Gary the
answer is go have fun asshole.
It would've been okay to
go to Vegas or Acapulco
or like do some dumb shit.
Like do you know what I mean?
Like so.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
I think I've had my fun in college though,
and now I feel like it's time to work.
- Well no, no.
That's the bullshit PR version Taylor.
The reality Taylor is
still fucking in that zone.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Don't beat yourself up.
Don't hold yourself accountable
to arbitrary bullshit fantasies.
Just put in work and enjoy that.
Enjoy eating shit and dirt
and bleeding and the grind,
and don't give a fuck about
what anybody else thinks.
Why you haven't done it?
Why are you doing that?
Have four jobs.
Fucking Wendy's, Wal-Mart,
your side hustle.
Work, train, learn.
Don't think you're a digital
expert just 'cause you're 22
and you have an Instagram account.
Show me how fucking shit you've sold
with your digital social media skills.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Do you understand?
- [Taylor] No, I do, yeah.
- You're just completely in the wrong,
and I'm holding you onto this
because you and 99% of the people
that are watching are
playing the same game.
- [Taylor] I know which is why
I wanted to ask the question.
I'm obviously not the only one.
- No, you're the majority
and the massive majority.
The question is you just need
to understand the following.
You can trick losers.
You're not tricking me.
- [Taylor] Good 'cause
I want honest answers.
- You don't need my honest answer.
You know you're not
tricking yourself either.
None of us are tricking ourselves.
I just remind you that you might be able
to trick your Uncle Hal
and you might be able
to trick your girlfriend that was
in your fucking college with you,
but you're not tricking a
winner when you're bullshitting.
Got it?
- [Taylor] Got it?
- So even if you're
posturing and pandering
and PR'ing yourself no
winner thinks you're winning.
- [Taylor] Yeah, 'cause I'm not.
- I know.
Work.
That's the answer to all these questions.
Learn things.
Do stuff.
Try to sell shit.
Learn how to make money.
Work.
- [Taylor] Alright, I will.
- Was this good?
- [Taylor] Awesome.
Thank you so much.
- Can you do me a huge favor?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Can you email me in 30
days and don't bullshit me.
What's your Twitter handle?
Or Instagram?
What's your Instagram?
That's fine.
- [Taylor] Instagram
is @thefabulousjourney.
- @Thefabulousjourney.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Me and my whole team in the entire
Vanyer nation is watching.
- [Taylor] Oh shit, okay.
Got it.
- I'm gonna smoke you
out of your bullshit.
- [Taylor] (laughs) Okay.
- Everybody's watching.
- [Taylor] Okay, I got it.
- Do you understand?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I like your blue dress.
- [Taylor] (laughs) Thank you.
I got it on sale.
- I like that answer.
That's the best thing
you said all fucking,
that's the best thing
you said this whole time.
Listen, slow and steady wins the race.
You're only competing with yourself.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Got it?
- [Taylor] Got it.
- Nobody else defines you.
Not me, not everybody
watching, not your mom,
not the fucking Kardashians.
You.
- [Taylor] Got it.
- You can grind and be
patient for 10 years everyday
and still be nine years younger than me
and I would trade places with you.
That's how amazing having
time on your side is.
- [Taylor] Yeah, time's everything.
- So use it.
- [Taylor] I will.
- Good.
See ya.
- [Taylor] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I'm super excited to be here.
You actually kind of changed a lot for me.
Oh shit.
It's a little crazy.
Little crazy.
- Tell me.
I mean it was such a viral moment.
- That and it was kind of
like a light switch for me.
I used to be really gung
ho, super energetic.
Always working.
Group up in my family business.
All that kind of stuff.
And then I don't know what
happened after graduation.
It kind of just went.
- It's what happens to a lot of people.
- Yeah.
It's the trick.
It's why I'm so passionate about doing
what I'm doing right now
for all of you characters
'cause I genuinely believe 22 to 28,
22 to 30 is tricky times.
- Yeah.
I think the biggest thing that's happened
in the last year since having
the conversation with Gary
is complete mental shifting
to like self-awareness,
and I mean he says patience,
but really like be patient
has been the biggest thing for me.
We're all so in our head.
It's crippling.
- And what's really tough for me is
that most of it is other people's voices
manifested into your head.
It sounds like your voice but it's not.
- So having that call with you
kind of was like a light switch.
Woke me up.
- Did it wake you up from the call itself,
or all the collateral that happened after?
- Both.
- 'Cause there was a
lot that happened there.
- Yeah both.
- Like the amount of like
smiling faces right now
on the other side of however
D. Rock is gonna edit this
is like you know a lot of.
I mean, you were probably one
of the most known characters.
You know?
- Yeah.
It's actually really funny
'cause I got flooded.
- I remember.
- With DMs of people saying we're watching
and the eyeball emojis which
was super intimidating.
- Of course.
- So, hearing from you.
- That was the point.
- I got pumped up with adrenalin,
and that having that as the
aftermath was like oh shit.
- Well that was the point to create
accountability after the fact.
That's why I went there.
- It worked.
So I ended up starting
my own online business,
and I've slowly been trying
to make something of it,
and I have a real clear vision
of what I want it to be,
but when it comes to
like process and steps
and like okay what's the next step?
Like what's those steps?
- That's not clear yet.
- No idea.
- Makes sense.
I mean look, until you're in
that mode to be an operator.
Like running a business
sounds great in theory.
- It's not.
- It's no different than anything else.
Like in theory it sounds
great to be a chef,
or you know like if there's such,
this is back like my
big thing with 22 to 30.
Everyone's like I'm
gonna start a business.
Cool.
But nobody says I'm gonna
be an NBA player cold at 22,
but it's the same thing.
Like being successful in business is hard.
Okay so keep going.
- So that was really cool
'cause what I started last March
with that is not what it is today.
- That's good.
- Which is really cool
just to watch that grow.
- That progression.
- And what I have now are ideas,
and I'm starting to try to create
like a campaign type of video.
I wanna create some sort video
that I could start to market.
Facebook ads is not what I know.
So I know people.
So it's kind of where I'm going with that.
The questions.
- Yeah go ahead.
- The question that I had though.
I had a couple.
But most specifically is how do you find
that person to help you grow the business?
'Cause I'm a very much I
know why I wanna do it.
I know the type of people I want.
I know.
- What are you selling?
- So it started as an apparel company,
but I actually want it
to be a community first.
So I wanna build a community
that totally encompasses
people who are like me.
People who wanna be entrepreneurs,
or they want to be creatives.
- Where is the community going to live?
- Global.
- Physically where's it gonna live?
- What do you mean?
- Is the community gonna live
in the comments section of your content?
- I don't want it to.
- Is it gonna live on an email?
Is it gonna live in a
closed Facebook group?
- It started as a Facebook group
connected to the I guess
brands Facebook group,
and I don't know how to begin to grow it.
I just wanna add some value.
- I think the thing that you have
to think about is the following.
It's the biggest mistake that so many
young entrepreneurs are making right now.
Everyone's like I'm
starting a lifestyle brand.
I know you're not saying that,
but you are kind of saying that.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
Cool, you're starting a
community around conversation.
What you have to first realize is
if you're gonna start a community,
and it's just about the organic community,
it means you're not gonna make
any money the first couple years.
So the first thing you have to decide is
how you're gonna live and
whether that's living at home
and not having any expenses
or having another job
and doing it from six
to two in the morning.
Both are cool but you have to make.
Remember the switch?
You have to start understanding right now
that if you're gonna do this right,
you're actually not gonna sell anything
for a couple of years.
- Which is what I totally understand.
- Good.
- After the first year, yeah.
- (laughs) Got it.
- After a year of that, I get it.
- Good.
So, you're in one big mode
of creating community.
I think a Facebook closed
group is a great idea.
- 'Kay.
- I think building out
an email list is smart.
- Okay.
- I think building out a text
message list is so smart.
- Okay.
- I think it's really smart to be
deep into the comments
section of your social,
and then extract them into first in line.
Got it?
- Yup.
- Watch what I do not what I say, right.
But the biggest thing you
first have to understand
and the biggest fucking thing
that people struggle with at
22 to 28 is being patient,
is building towards something real.
You have to realize how awesome it is
to not have to ask anybody
for money for three years
because everybody else is
asking for people's money.
- And I don't feel like
I need to ask for money.
Like I've never felt
like I needed funding.
- Good.
So then I would be honest with you.
I don't think you need that.
Now I can tell you I don't think
you need your business partner.
You need to build a community.
- Okay.
- You don't need an operations
or business person yet.
You're not doing business.
- That's true.
- Got it?
So what you need to do is pour your heart
and soul into conversations.
I would highly recommend showcasing
other people in the community.
So I, if I were you, would
do a Facebook Live every week
with one of the commentors
from the community
because that would get other
people in the community
to comment more which would
make the community better
because they're trying
to win the golden ticket
to be on the Facebook Live.
See where I'm going?
- I like that.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
You're welcome.
- That's how I would do it.
- Okay 'cause I've actually.
I wanna funnel a lot of
my personal following
into that group 'cause
it's kind of the same.
- So I would throw right
hooks on Instagram stories.
- Okay.
- Swipe up join the group.
It's a good way to not, it's a
good way to throw right hooks
without throwing too many right hooks.
Stories I think are more
kind of like they're so much.
It's kind of like Twitter.
You should add something
to your email signature
with a link to it.
It's a very lightweight way to do it.
Every time you're emailing
somebody, they might see it.
- I have my social media profiles
I guess in my email picture.
- Put your group in there.
Join the community.
- I like that.
- Thank you.
- The other thing I had an idea
on was I started this thing.
I have a personal website just
connected to my Instagram,
and I called it people I know
'cause I think people
always want a recommendation
for someone they know so
throughout the last year
connected with a ton of
people through the Instagram
from Vanyer Nation and--
- Do people still pop up
because the content's on the internet?
- All the time.
I mean I was flooded at first.
I think I got 8000 like
within 24 hours followers,
and it's progressively just grown
to now it's 26,000 I think but I get,
I try to do all my DMs but
it still just says 99 plus
in the message requests at all times.
- I know that life.
- And they're all commenting back
from the video basically.
- Do you get razzed?
Do you a lot of people like
you fuck like I would assume--
- No.
- Really?
That's so awesome.
- Here's the cool thing that happened.
- I would've thought at least 20%
would have been like wake the fuck up.
You know just by the nature.
- A couple did and in the comment section,
everyone attacked back like I
never commented back to them.
I'm like I'm not gonna do that.
- You're not sure yeah.
- But my followers started to comment back
basically doing it for
me and then it just died.
So there's like zero negative anymore.
- Makes me happy.
- Yeah and then the other cool thing is
they're all damning me
basically saying thank you
and I'm like I didn't do anything.
Thank Gary.
- Well it takes two to tango, right.
It's just a moment in time.
- It is.
- It's just a moment time.
Here's the best part.
This is what's great about documenting
this whole journey for me.
Like this is so interesting.
You know like in so many ways.
You have to take the momentum of that call
and apply it now.
What you need to do now.
- That's what I'm trying to do.
- Like all these cute
questions you have here,
let me give you the only
answer that matters.
I'm being dead serious with you.
Every minute you have for them.
Now you don't have the same.
All you have for them is
you're living the same life
and you're over-communicating your truths.
A lot of people hold them in.
That's how you can win the most.
Today was a great day I saw Gary.
Tomorrow's a bad day.
All that.
Document thing not creating right.
But the other biggest
thing you had to do is
showcase them within you.
This can't be just, if you're
gonna build a community,
can't be just about you.
It was easier for me to be about me
because I'm coming from an expertise
not just a documenting place.
I put in the 20 years of work and skills
to be able to be the talker.
And when you're the documenter
of something like this,
I think it's more powerful
for you to bring them into it.
- Okay.
- I'm telling you Facebook Live.
- Live with it.
- It's going to.
Like kind of just like how
is your week kind of segment.
Like with that person.
- I did something like that at one point.
I made a post.
I don't even remember.
But I was like I wanna choose five people
and just zoom with you
like have a zoom call
and that was really cool.
- Facebook Live 'cause the
Facebook group is your big thing.
- Okay, I like that.
- And I would start
using Facebook Messenger
as much as possible, too.
- The AI version of it?
- No, you human.
- Just personally okay.
- Facebook.
You have to understand.
I asked you the most important question,
which is where is this going to live?
Your answer was Facebook.
- Yeah.
- So Live and Messenger need to create
that whole you know kind of stratosphere.
Make sense?
- You think building a community
through Facebook is
still the place to do it?
- I think Facebook groups is
an incredible place to do it.
- Okay.
- I do and even though you're community
probably will skew young and not overly
spending time on Facebook,
everybody still kind of has it
or could have it and Facebook
groups infrastructure
is a very good infrastructure
for this kind of shit.
- Okay.
- Matter fact it's one of the
things I wanna do more of.
- Okay 'cause that was the
one thing that I wasn't--
- I got it.
You need a home.
And I think the group can help you.
I like Facebook groups.
- Cool 'cause I--
- But listen to me.
Are you doing anything?
Do you have a job?
- Yeah, I work for my mom.
She's got family business.
- I remember.
Great so that's even better.
Like make sure you deliver for that,
but like every fucking minute.
- Okay.
- Look, this is something
I think people forgot.
I was running wine library
and building wine library TV.
I used to run the business 'til 7:30.
Drive back home to New York,
and from 8:30 to two in the morning,
I just answered all my email,
all my comments on my
WordPress from Wine Library TV,
and went on Twitter and searched
wine conversation and engaged.
I used to go to sleep at 2:30 to 3:30
after I'd already made it
to build what I've built
for four years everyday.
- Okay.
It works.
- It works but it's you
know it's like a brain fuck.
Like I'm telling you, you
gotta do it completely all in.
Five, six hours a day.
Seven hours a day after you
work on the family business
until like midnight, one
o'clock, two o'clock,
and this is just based on your ambition.
Like by the way, you can
do whatever you want.
You can hang out everyday
but if you want it to happen.
- I want to do that.
- Okay well if you wanna do
it, that's what you have to do
and you have to do it for
three years and ask for nothing
because at the end of three years,
when you ask for people
to buy one tee shirt,
you'll sale more tee shirts after giving
three years of love in one day
than you would've have in all three years
if you sold them every fucking day.
- Yeah, and I've stopped.
I don't believe in the
buy my shirt type of crap.
So I kinda cut all that.
- Because you saw that you
didn't have the leverage.
- Yeah like why would people
wanna buy my tee shirt?
- That's right.
You had my fan base trying
to build a community with you
off of this magic moment.
Of course they weren't gonna buy it.
It was fun.
I caught wind of it at one point.
Maybe like three or four months after.
Like somehow I saw something.
And I was like watching it.
And I almost DM'd you.
And I was like I'm gonna let
her go through this herself
and I'm gonna see what she does with it.
- Okay.
- I'm glad that you got to this place.
Now you know it for yourself.
Now it's time you spend the
next fucking three, four years
of your life building equity,
then you can figure out
what to do with that equity.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm trying to
figure out what that equity is.
- And that's what so great about.
I did, too.
Took me years of engaging
before I was like okay wow.
Do you think I knew?
When you are yourself, when you are you,
you don't know what makes you special.
You don't have context.
All the things that people admire me for,
they just seem normal.
I didn't even know patience was a thing.
It's just what I did.
Like I didn't know any of
these things were a thing.
I didn't realize I was
emotionally intelligent.
I didn't realize I loved
empathy and gratitude.
It took me time.
- Which is totally what I went through.
In the last couple years I went
to some Tony Robbins events and stuff.
So like figuring out who I
am like what I'm good at--
- Yes but look you went to those events,
and yet we still had the call
and you were fucking nowhere.
Right?
Or you're talking 'bout
you went this year?
- I went after.
- Got it, got it, got it.
- I was like wait.
- Got it, got it.
- Yeah I went after.
- Got it, perfect.
- Maybe six months after.
- Got it.
It's about actions.
Whether you fucking get a call
with me or go to an event.
Bullshit.
It's about actions.
But you've gotta get that trigger.
- Yup.
- You're on the path.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, that post where I say like
close your eyes until your 29,
that's basically the advice
I'm giving you right now.
Like you know what to do now.
Just fucking give but the one thing is
there's only two things
I think you can give.
You've built this little
base off of this moment.
Awareness to the rest of
community members of each other
by doing these Friday livestreams
or however you decide.
You might wanna do one every night.
- Okay.
- And your truths of the
ups and downs along the way.
Those are the only two things.
Documenting and being
a platform for others
is the leverage for now.
It's all you've got to give.
- Okay.
Now what do you think of documenting
just like webcam style straight on.
- Sure.
- Do you think just
documenting the whole day?
- Sure.
I mean, documenting
the whole day is tough.
- I tried it and it was like I can't.
- But you can do Snap along
the way like stories, you know.
Like don't overthink that.
- Okay.
- Alright, I gotta bounce.
- I don't know what
else to ask you anyway.
- Good 'cause I've given
you the fucking answer.
- I know.
I know what to do.
It's just patience.
- It's hard.
It's hard.
I know you know what to do.
It's like close your eyes for four years.
Nothing good is gonna
happen for four years.
- That's probably the biggest
thing that set in for me.
Like it'll happen just.
- If you do the fucking
right things for four years.
- I agree.
I don't know.
It's just been this crazy year
of complete self-awareness.
Doubling down on my strengths,
and not focusing on the
stuff that I'm not great at.
So I tried really hard to want to do
the whole Facebook ads thing,
and I tried to do it for my mom's company.
I didn't know what I was doing.
It wasn't really something
I was passion about.
It was Facebook ads.
So don't do the things
that you're passion about
and the one thing that
I really really did,
which I totally totally
recommend is do more.
Try new things.
Get new hobbies.
Do some sports.
Start painting.
Like literally the more you try,
the more you'll know
if you like it or not,
which tells you more about yourself,
which tells you maybe if you wanna
completely change industries.
I went to school for fashion and design,
so I started a fashion apparel business,
and found that designing's
kind of not what I wanna do.
I don't wanna sow clothes.
I don't wanna, you know,
do the fabric thing.
I love the creativity behind it.
I love the designing.
I love picking the colors and
drawing and all that stuff,
and only through doing
the stuff did I figure out
what part of it I liked.
Do more (laughs).
It's pretty simple.